City of London (Confidentiality) - Part
Greater London is known for its historical landmarks, modern skyscrapers and its old markets
And its famous bridges. It can be said that it is the financial capital of the world and seat more than eleven
* A * people.
Moment, what? Eleven thousand?
That's true. But London is a different place from London
It is also known for its historical landmarks, modern skyscrapers and old markets
Its famous bridges are also home to the government, the royal family and seven million people.
But if you look at a map of London drawn by a professional map painter this map will contain
A space of one square mile in the middle of which is almost - there lies the city of London
Within the city named London.
No matter how confusing the two names are, London has a separate municipality
Its municipality, which collects separate taxes to finance police forces, is elected
Different laws.
Mayor of London has a prestigious title is "Lord Lord of London Honorable"
To match his luxurious costume. He also travels with his doctrines and works
In the municipal building while the Mayor of London is wearing a formal suit and is traveling by bicycle and working in
Office building.
The city of London has its own flag and logo, which is great for London
Which misses the two sad.
In short, the City of London has the right to act as a State in the United Kingdom
Just a city with a strange location. To distinguish, some organizations run the city of London
I come from the United Kingdom several hundred years ago.
How did the United Kingdom end up in the cities of London? Briefly? Because: Romans.
Two thousand years ago they came to Great Britain, killed a group of priests and established a site
Commercial on the banks of the Thames River. And because they were Roman they did what the Romans did
They put laws, increased trade exchange, built temples, public baths, roads, bridges,
A wall protects their work.
The wall from which the city of London remains so far. Although the Romans came and went
And the kingdoms of the kingdoms and kingdoms have collapsed, the wall has done its work
And the city fever inside. The city ruled itself and dealt commercially with the world to grow richer.
A thousand years after the Romans (still a thousand years from now) when William the Conqueror came
To Great Britain all opened up and began modern British history
The walled city of London found it harder to defeat the peasantry
In the open fields.
So he agreed on the rights and privileges of the people of the city of London they were used to
As opposed to recognizing him as a new king.
Although immediately after negotiations, William built the towers around the city of London
Which protected William from the locals at the same time to defend
Against the Viking from abroad.
This was the beginning of a thousand-year tradition in which the royal family renews this approval
The city of London has its own place, and its privileged location. It is best to leave it alone
With no confidence at the same time.
Many members of the royal court believe that the city of London is strong and too rich. They built a capital
New near them, called Westminster, to rival the city of London,
To try to absorb its power and economic wealth. This was the beginning of the second London.
Over the centuries, Westminster expanded and merged into neighboring cities
To surround the separate city of London within its walls. But people started naming
This urban area "London" became officially named when the two cities merged the two cities together
Under one municipality and one mayor.
But the mayor of London still has no powers over the small city of London
Which has laws and traditions unmatched anywhere in the country or even the world.
For example, the king can not enter the city of London whenever he wants, but it must be
The permission is therefore requested from the Lord Mayor at a special ceremony. While it is not legally required,
But the ceremony is required.
The City of London also has its own representative in Parliament and the post of Representative
Protection of private city privileges.
Because of this, some of the laws adopted by Parliament do not apply to the city of London at times.
The most prominent observation is the voting method, which we will discuss in the future. But if you have curiosity, it is possible to say
Unlike any other place in the UK, voting in London includes medieval guilds and modern companies.
Finally, London City owns and also occupies many land and buildings outside
Its borders, making it very rich
When you start looking for a city logo you will find it in many places, but most
Note is the Tower Bridge, which with it is located in "London" but is managed by the City of London,
These slogans are everywhere when you link to the city of London and its wealth and independence
Making them in a great temptation to proponents of conspiracy theory. Add to that the oldest Masonic forum
It will not wait long before the crazy Internet community cries out for clandestine gatherings
Which controls the world by making the economy from within the city of London
(And do not forget the evil queen that is really behind it all)
To put the conspiracy theories aside, the City of London is not an independent nation like
The Vatican, no matter how much you read online, is rather a very special site
In the UK with a very long and complex history.
The wall that began all this 2,000 years ago has now disappeared
"London" and the secret city inside are not clear-cut. However, if you visit London next time
I passed a small dragon in the street, it is still guarding the entrance to this city
Within the city within the state within the state.